Matthew Perry had the type of success
that most can only dream of — but it
also came with a cost. From numerous
hospitalizations to the many years he
spent battling his addiction, Perry's
personal life was far from perfect.
Matthew Perry was raised in Ottawa, Canada, and
his parents were significant figures. His father,
John Bennett Perry, was an American actor best
recognized for minor roles in films like "The
Legend of the Lone Ranger." Meanwhile,
Perry's mother, Suzanne Marie Morrison,
was a former beauty queen who served as press
secretary to the country's Prime Minister.
"They're both people that take over
a room, you know, when they come in."
Unfortunately, the pair separated before
their son reached his first birthday. Perry's
mother would find a new partner in celebrated
"Dateline" correspondent Keith Morrison. However,
the young performer admitted that he didn't
see much of them while he was growing up. In
his 2022 memoir, "Friends, Lovers, and
the Big Terrible Thing," Perry wrote:
"I spent a great deal of time alone."
Even more tragically, when it came
to seeing his father, Perry wrote,
"I saw his face more often on TV or
in magazines than I did in reality."
Perry also admitted that he started misbehaving
at an early age. By the age of 10, he was smoking
and stealing money. Meanwhile, Perry admitted
to having his first taste of alcohol at 14.
It may come as a surprise that before Perry
became an actor, he had his sights set on
a tennis career. The actor first hit the court
when he was 4 years old. Training nearly 10 hours
a day by age 13, he ranked among the best for
juniors in his home country of Canada. However,
when Perry moved in with his father in
California the reality of a sports career
seemed much more daunting. He explained
in a 2012 interview with Men's Health:
"I was a very good tennis player in Ottawa,
Canada — nationally ranked when I was, like,
13. Then I moved to Los Angeles
when I was 15, and everyone in
L.A. just killed me. I was pretty great
in Canada. Not so much in Los Angeles."
Thankfully, the young star had a
backup plan. He told Men's Health:
"I realized I wouldn't be playing tennis for
a living, so I went for acting. Are tennis
and acting alike? I don't know.
They're both very mental games."
While his career ultimately went in a different
direction, tennis remained a passion for
the actor as his last public appearance was
reportedly at the 2023 French Open in Paris.
Matthew Perry openly expressed that the
most significant demon of his life was
his addiction struggles. His memoirs'
release just one year before his passing
illuminated many of the challenges
that the actor faced. He described
himself as an alcoholic since he first
started drinking as a teenager. However,
his addictions overtook his life after he
was prescribed painkillers following a jet
ski accident in 1997, resulting in his first
stay at a rehabilitation clinic the same year.
By 2000, Perry's drinking led to him being
hospitalized with pancreatitis. That same year,
he crashed his Porsche into the steps of his
Hollywood home. In a 2002 interview with People,
the actor described the amount of drugs and
alcohol he was consuming at the time. He told the
outlet that he'd ingest as many as "55 Vicodin" a
day while drinking upwards of "a quart of vodka."
"I had to wake up and realize that I needed to
get 55 of them or I was going to be real sick."
In a separate 2022 interview
with People, Perry admitted,
"I didn't know how to stop. If the
police came over to my house and said,
'If you drink tonight, we're going to
take you to jail,' I'd start packing.
I couldn't stop because the disease
and the addiction is progressive. So,
it gets worse and worse as you grow older."
Matthew Perry's addiction problems ultimately
collided with his acting career. Perry landed the
role of Chandler Bing when he was 24 years old,
just as his addiction was truly beginning
to take the reins. He told People:
"I could handle it, kind of. But by the time I was
34, I was really entrenched in a lot of trouble."
While appearing on BBC Radio
2 in 2016, he was questioned
on his least favorite episode from
"Friends," and he candidly replied,
"I think the answer is I don't
remember three years of it."
He went on to admit that Season 3 to Season
6 were blurred in his memories. The actor
struggled to look back at his time on
the beloved sitcom as it was equally
one of the most challenging eras of his
life. He told Tom Power in an interview:
"I can't watch the show, because I was
brutally thin and being beaten down so
badly by the disease. I could tell season
by season by how I looked, and I don't
think anybody else can, but I certainly could."
As Perry's struggles with addiction intensified,
he worried about disappointing his co-stars.
The actor said in an ABC News interview:
"I made a rule that I would never
drink or take anything at work. But
I would show up blindly hung over.
I thought I was hiding it so well."
Unfortunately, the five other prominent
"Friends" were each affected by Perry's
struggles at one point or another.
Lisa Kudrow told the New York Times:
"When Matthew was sick, it was
not fun. We were just hopelessly
standing on the sidelines. We were hurting a lot."
Meanwhile, Matt LeBlanc also admitted
to People that he tried to help his
onscreen roommate but ultimately felt like
there was little he could do. However,
it was Jennifer Anniston whom Perry
praised in his ABC interview, saying,
"She was the one that reached out the most.
You know, I'm really grateful to her for that."
Perry conceded that he would not
have made it through 10 seasons
without his castmates, writing in his memoir,
"They were patient. It's like penguins.
Penguins, in nature, when one is sick,
or when one is very injured, the other penguins
surround it and prop it up. They walk around
it until that penguin can walk on its own.
That's kind of what the cast did for me."
Perry had a lifelong grudge
match with his addiction.
One of his biggest realizations came
when he put the numbers down for how
much he has invested into getting
clean. He told the New York Times:
"I've probably spent $9 million or
something trying to get sober. It's
still a day-to-day process of getting better."
In addition to the time and
effort he put into sobriety,
Perry also did his part to give back. In 2013,
he opened the doors of his Malibu beach house,
transitioning it into a dedicated sober living
facility for men suffering from addiction.
"If somebody comes up to me and says,
'I can't stop drinking. Can you help me?'
I can say yes and follow up and do it."
The aptly named Perry House was eventually
sold in 2015 because of the high operating
costs of living in Malibu. However, Perry
continued to take significant pride in being
able to help those who have suffered the same
hurdles as himself. He told People magazine:
"When I die, I'd like 'Friends' to
be listed behind helping people."
After decades of pushing his health to the brink,
the substance use caught up with Matthew Perry
in 2018. The actor suffered a gastrointestinal
perforation and narrowly survived the
traumatic event. He told People in 2022;
"The doctors told my family that I had a
two percent chance to live. I was put on
a thing called an ECMO machine, which
does all the breathing for your heart
and your lungs. And that's called
a Hail Mary. No one survives that."
Perry revealed that the life-threatening situation
put him in a coma for two weeks followed
by a five-month hospital stay. However,
the close call had lasting implications on his
life. He had over a dozen surgeries and carried
a colostomy bag for nine months as a result
of his health complications. He recalled:
"My therapist said, 'The next time
you think about taking Oxycontin,
just think about having a colostomy
bag for the rest of your life.' A
little window opened and I crawled through
it and I no longer want Oxycontin anymore."
Undoubtedly, Perry counted his
blessings and used his second
chance at life to complete
his memoirs. He told People:
"There were five people put on an ECMO machine
that night and the other
four died and I survived."
Many of the details of Matthew Perry's life
have only become available thanks to the
actor's 2022 memoir. However,
when the book was published,
Perry received heavy backlash from fans and
celebrities alike for taking punches at one
of Hollywood's most beloved figures:
Keanu Reeves. Perry wrote in the book:
"Why is it that the original thinkers like River
Phoenix and Heath Ledger die, but
Keanu Reeves still walks among us?"
By all accounts, the "Friends" actor had never
professionally crossed paths with the "Matrix"
star, making the name drop more confusing. In
the wake of the one-sided feud, many celebrities
vocalized their defense for Reeves. Billy Baldwin
said in a post on X, formerly known as Twitter,
"In a world full of Matthew
Perry's ... be a Keanu Reeves."
Following the negative reaction,
Perry was quick to apologize. The
actor said in a statement to Deadline:
"I'm actually a big fan of Keanu. I just
chose a random name, my mistake. I apologize.
I should have used my own name instead."
Throughout his life, Matthew Perry dated
some of the biggest actresses in Hollywood.
Some of the high-profile women that crossed
paths with the actor included Julia
Roberts and Gwyneth Paltrow. Sadly,
despite rubbing elbows with some of the most elite
bachelorettes, Perry never held down a committed
relationship for long. While talking about his
past romantic life, Perry wrote in his book,
"I need love but I don't trust it. If I drop my
game like Chandler and show you who I really am
you might notice me — but worse you might notice
me and might leave me, and I can't have that."
On one of his most heartbreaking
breakups, he wrote,
"I was broken, bent, unlovable. So instead
of facing the inevitable agony of losing her,
I broke up with the beautiful
and brilliant Julia Roberts."
"Are you dating this Matthew Perry guy?"
"I am dating this Matthew Perry guy."
The "Friends" star seemed to have finally found
love when he got engaged to Molly Hurwitz in
2020. However, the pair called off the wedding
a few months later, with Perry telling People,
"Sometimes things just don't work
out and this is one of them."
With all the tribulations that Matthew
Perry faced throughout his life,
the actor had seemingly gotten himself back on a
healthy track. While promoting his book in 2022,
he boasted a clean lifestyle. In his
interview with People, he even joked,
"I'm pretty healthy now. I've got to not go
to the gym much more because I don't want
to only be able to play superheroes. But
no, I'm a pretty healthy guy right now."
With the worst seemingly
behind the beloved sitcom star,
it was extra shocking when it was revealed on
October 28, 2023 that Perry had died from an
apparent drowning in a hot tub. Perry's
family wrote in a statement to People:
"We are heartbroken by the tragic loss
of our beloved son and brother. Matthew
brought so much joy to the world,
both as an actor and a friend."
Additionally, they sent a message
to Perry's fans across the globe:
"You all meant so much to him and we
appreciate the tremendous outpouring of love."